Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Hélène VERNET
Bonjour.
Croyez-vous au bonheur ?
Public : Oui !
Qui croit au bonheur ici ?
Jusqu'au bout là-bas, bravo !
Bon, c'est bon, je pars !
(Rires)
Moi, très longtemps,
je n'ai pas cru au bonheur.
Je n'y croyais pas.
Le bonheur, en fait, et ce que j'ai
envie de vous raconter aujourd'hui,
c'est que, c'est étonnant,
mais non seulement je crois au bonheur,
mais j'en ai fait mon métier.
Quand j'ai rencontré
l'équipe de TEDxRennes,
ils m'ont dit : « Pourquoi le bonheur ? »
Et là, j'ai eu un temps de pause,
un peu prise à froid, et j'ai dit :
« Eh bien, parce que la mort. »
Quand j'avais 3 ans et demi,
un de mes premiers souvenirs,
une image que j'ai
gardée toute ma vie,
ce sont les doigts
de ma grande-tante, Nénène.
Elle a le chapelet autour de ses mains,
enroulé, comme si elle priait.
Elle est dans son habit de bretonne,
avec les grandes manches, toute en noir,
et son tablier en velours noir.
Elle a sa coiffe
du pays lorientais, plate -
pas le bigouden - plate, en dentelle.
Et autour, il y a
des Bretonnes qui prient.
Mon oncle m'a prise,
m'a emmenée dans la cour,
et m'a expliqué le Paradis.
Je ne sais pas si vous vous souvenez
du jour où vous avez réalisé
que vous alliez mourir,
mais je trouve que c'est quand
même un fait, dans la vie,
aussi important que l'homme
qui a marché sur la Lune,
ou les Twin Towers et
les avions qui rentrent dedans.
Et pourtant, c'est rare
qu'on se souvienne de ça.
En fait, je me suis dit :
« En fin de compte,
on est en train de m'expliquer
qu'on est tous sur un tapis roulant,
et que gentiment, tous inexorablement,
on va vers cette issue fatale
où on va perdre notre corps,
notre conscience,
on va mourir.
Mais, c'est l'arnaque !
C'est insupportable ! »
C'est une idée
que je trouvais... immorale.
Qui a inventé ce truc ?
J'ai traîné cette angoisse
de la mort toute mon enfance.
Littéralement, j'avais
des crises de larmes.
Moi, je ne voulais pas mourir.
Et puis à 21 ans,
je suis partie en Malaisie.
Je pars en vacances en Malaisie,
et là, j'ai une révélation.
En fait, je me suis dit :
« Qui je suis, moi ?
Qu'est-ce que je veux ?
Et ce serait quoi, mon bonheur à moi ? »
Parce que je ne l'avais toujours pas
trouvé, j'avais ces angoisses.
Donc, je ne vais pas
utiliser mon billet retour.
Mais voilà, je n'avais pas d'argent,
donc j'ai commencé à travailler.
Je suis devenue serveuse à Hong Kong.
À 21 ans, je n'avais jamais bu
un verre d'alcool de ma vie.
Pour une Bretonne, ce n'est pas normal,
mais c'est comme ça.
Les clients mettaient
des petits schnaps allemands,
et à chaque fois que je passais,
je devais prendre un schnaps.
Mais ce qu'ignorent les Allemands,
les Hongkongais, les Chinois,
c'est que justement, j'ai des globules
bretons, donc je tiens l'alcool !
(Rires)
En fait, j'ai parcouru
la planète comme ça.
Je suis partie travailler,
par exemple, au Guatemala.
Je travaillais dans des ruines mayas
au milieu de la jungle, avec 70 hommes,
à creuser la terre dès 7 h du matin.
Et on mangeait des haricots
rouges du matin au soir,
le matin, le midi et le soir.
Et le soir, on allait jouer au foot
dans les ruines, sur la place royale.
J'ai vécu aussi au Sénégal
avec des bonnes sœurs.
Je travaillais dans
le centre de couture.
J'ai parcouru la planète un peu partout,
que ce soit cueillir
des pommes en Nouvelle-Zélande,
travailler dans un
orphelinat en Thaïlande,
ou bien dans un cinq étoiles au Maroc.
J'ai couru, comme ça,
la planète, à la recherche.
Mais c'est quoi ?
En fin de compte, quand on court
la planète et qu'on a toutes ces vies,
il y a une sorte d'errance.
Je me suis aussi perdue.
En fin de compte, vous vous
rendez compte en voyageant
que votre vision avec
votre culture et vos croyances
où « la vie, c'est ceci »,
« la vie, c'est cela »,
s'écroule aussi, parce qu'il y a
autant de visions de la vérité
que d'êtres humains sur Terre.
Et donc, je me suis dit :
« Je ne peux pas faire ça,
donc je vais rentrer dans une voie
un peu plus conventionnelle. »
Et je suis devenue acheteuse,
d'abord dans une PME,
dans le centre de la France,
et c'est une aventure, vivre
dans le centre de la France ! (Rires)
Et je partais négocier au Pakistan,
avec des directeurs d'usine
qui faisaient des gants en coton,
ou je me retrouvais à Calcutta,
dans les tanneries,
ou en Chine - encore en Chine -
et là, pour vous faire flancher
dans les négociations,
à table, ils vous font boire.
C'était drôle, quand quelqu'un voulait
boire, tout le monde devait boire,
mais ce qu'ils ne savaient pas,
c'est que je suis bretonne ! (Rires)
Donc, je tenais l'alcool, ah ! ah !
Puis, j'ai travaillé
dans des multinationales.
Alors là, j'étais à New York,
j'avais des tailleurs, des talons hauts,
et je négociais
des millions de dollars.
J'avais une voiture
qui était tellement grande
que j'étais obligée de monter dans le
coffre pour récupérer les courses au fond.
C'était la grande vie, et j'ai continué
dans d'autres multinationales.
Je suis partie travailler à Amsterdam,
puis comme consultante en Angleterre.
Et pourtant,
ce n'était toujours pas ça.
Mais, ce qui est dérangeant,
c'est qu'en tous cas moi,
je savais que ce n'était pas ça,
mais pas ce qu'était le « ça »,
ce qu'on devait mettre dedans.
Alors, j'ai tout plaqué.
Et j'ai bu une petite
gorgée d'eau, comme ça.
J'ai tout plaqué, et j'avais envie
de vivre en France, de vivre à Paris.
En fait, j'avais envie de vivre dans
ma langue, dans ma gastronomie,
dans ces paysages, ce climat.
Je trouve que la France
est un pays magnifique, beau.
J'avais envie d'être ici,
donc, j'ai tout plaqué.
Mais voilà, je n'avais
ni travail, ni revenu,
donc pas de statut social.
Comment on se définit
quand on n'a pas de statut social ?
En fait, il a fallu traverser mes peurs :
la peur de manquer,
la peur de me planter,
la peur, tout simplement,
de ne pas être aimée, reconnue.
Mais bon, on les traverse peu à peu.
Et pas à pas, je me suis dit :
« Puisque je me pose des
questions existentielles sur la vie,
je vais acheter une caméra et les poser
à des gens qui semblent savoir. »
Et je suis allée rencontrer
des philosophes, des entrepreneurs,
des résilients, des gens qui sont
passés par des épreuves difficiles
et qui ont ces petites pépites de bonheur.
J'ai rencontré des gens extraordinaires,
comme un alchimiste que
j'ai interviewé au Père Lachaise.
Pour cet alchimiste, le but n'est pas
de transformer le plomb en or,
le but de l'alchimie, c'est le bonheur.
Donc, on est allé au Père Lachaise
qu'il m'a décrypté.
J'ai rencontré... oh, tellement de gens,
tellement de gens extraordinaires.
Par exemple, Michel Vaujour,
qui a passé 25 ans en prison,
c'est lui qui s'est échappé
de prison en hélicoptère, de la Santé.
Je suis sûre que certains
ici s'en rappellent... Oui.
Michel s'est pris une balle dans la tête,
et ça a transformé sa vision du monde.
(En riant) Ah oui !
(Rires)
Allez voir l'interview, vous comprendrez.
Je sais que comme ça, ça paraît bizarre.
J'ai rencontré Magali Saby,
handicapée de naissance,
qui fait partie d'une troupe de danse.
Plein de gens extraordinaires !
Et un jour, une jeune femme
m'a contactée qui s'appelle Jessica,
et ensemble, on a créé
un laboratoire du bonheur.
Vous savez, la mission de ce laboratoire
qui s'appelle « Happylab »,
c'est de faire monter la France
sur le podium des pays
les plus heureux au monde,
parce que c'est possible.
Là je vous vois sceptiques,
mais c'est possible !
En fait, on part du principe
que toutes ces perles,
ces choses que j'ai apprises sont
des clés que l'on peut s'échanger.
En donnant les outils à chacun de nous
pour trouver son propre bonheur,
ensemble, on peut créer
de nouvelles solutions
on peut se ré-ouvrir au monde.
C'est souvent la peur
qui nous empêche de dire :
« Oui, moi, j'ai une voix. J'ai
des solutions pour la collectivité. »
Donc, on a créé Happylab.
Aujourd'hui, des milliers
de gens en France,
même à Rennes,
font partie d'Happylab et font des
événements un peu partout en France.
Alors, comment je sais
que c'est « ça » ?
Vous voyez ce « ça », comment
je sais que je suis heureuse ?
La semaine dernière, je suis
allée déjeuner chez mon frère -
Je sais que ça ne vous intéresse pas
mais je raconte ma vie -
et j'ai découvert
que j'avais dans le cou, là...
Regardez, là...
Plissez les yeux... là !
Non ? Eh bien là, j'ai une boule.
Je ne suis jamais malade,
parce que je suis bretonne.
On est à Rennes,
alors j'y vais sur la Bretagne.
J'ai découvert cette boule,
et je me suis dit :
« Si ça se trouve, je vais voir
un médecin qui va me dire :
"Mais mademoiselle, vous
n'avez plus qu'un an à vivre." »
J'ai beau contempler ma mort chaque jour,
si on m’annonçait que
je n'avais qu'un an à vivre,
et si on vous annonçait
que vous n'aviez qu'un an à vivre,
que feriez-vous de cette année ?
Moi, je sais.
Je sais exactement ce que je ferais
si j'avais encore un an à vivre.
Je continuerais à faire exactement
ce que je fais aujourd'hui.
Non, je ne changerais rien.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'en fin de compte,
je suis heureuse d'avoir
eu si peur de la mort,
d'avoir cherché.
Je pense que ça m'a
empêchée de m'endormir.
Et du coup, aujourd'hui,
je me rends compte que c'est fabuleux,
car même s'il y a eu des milliards
d'hommes avant nous qui ont vécu,
des milliards qui vivront après nous,
ma sensation, c'est que
je suis le héros du présent.
Nous sommes les héros du présent
aujourd'hui, maintenant.
Donc ce qui m'intéresse
et l'intérêt de cette mort,
c'est qu'elle donne la force
à ce moment, à cette vie maintenant.
Et du coup, qu'est-ce
qu'on fait de ce présent ?
Je voulais partager avec vous
un message que j'ai reçu ce matin.
On m'a posé la question :
« Pourquoi aller sur une scène
et parler du bonheur ?
Après tout, pourquoi
tu nous racontes ta vie ? »
Et ce matin, j'ai reçu ce message.
J'ai une chaîne YouTube,
et les gens peuvent laisser
des commentaires.
Et j'ai reçu ça : « C'est Joanna,
l'idiote heureuse,
l'idiote nunuche et ricaneuse,
bercée par le bonheur.
Classique certes, mais insupportable.
Mais imbécile heureuse
ne comprendra pas. »
Je vous passe la suite parce que
ça devient très, très, très grossier.
Et en fait, je me suis dit :
« Mais c'est fabuleux.
Cette personne vient de m'expliquer
pourquoi je monte ici. »
Pourquoi je monte ici ? Parce que je
pense que le bonheur, c'est politique,
le bonheur de pouvoir dire
« Je suis heureuse » -
et on peut aussi parler
de ça - c'est important.
Cette personne, c'est-à-dire les gens
qui sont dans la violence,
s'expriment tout le temps.
Donc je suis ici -
et je sais enfin pourquoi -
pour vous dire qu'il y a plein de gens
qui ont envie aussi d'aller vers « ça »,
d'aller vers le bonheur, de le comprendre,
J'ai des antisèches !
J'ai lu un article et découvert un mot,
il n'y a pas longtemps,
c'est « entéléchie », vous connaissez ?
Entéléchie, c'est, dans un article
que j'ai traduit de l'anglais :
« le perfectionnisme appliqué à soi-même.
C'est le désir d'évoluer, de se concentrer
sur ses objectifs les plus élevés. »
Je me suis dit :
« Ça, c'est mon bonheur à moi »,
c'est-à-dire d'apprendre et de progresser.
Et en même temps, dans ce mot,
entéléchie, il y a « en chie ».
(Rires)
Eh bien, oui.
Le bonheur, ce n'est pas la béatitude,
ce n'est pas tout plat.
Le bonheur pour moi,
ça peut aussi être dur.
Et je voudrais finir avec cette anecdote.
Au début de l'année,
j'ai eu une grosse déception,
et j'étais triste.
Et je n'arrivais pas
à me défaire de cette tristesse.
Donc, c'était un matin, il pleuvait.
Et j'avais un parapluie.
Il y a quelques années
j'ai interviewé Luc Simonet.
Luc Simonet est le président de la Ligue
des Optimistes du Royaume de Belgique.
(Rires)
Il m'a offert un parapluie, avec écrit :
« C'est un beau jour de pluie. »
J'avais donc mon grand parapluie
de la Ligue des Optimistes
et j'étais sous la pluie.
Je marchais, et le feu piéton
venait de passer au rouge.
Et là, dans les cheveux
du monsieur juste devant moi,
je remarque des petites
perles de pluie... Très, très beau !
Et je ne sais pas
ce qui me passe par la tête,
je fais un pas en avant.
Et je me retrouve, épaule contre épaule,
sous le grand parapluie,
avec un homme, la cinquantaine,
que je ne connais pas.
Ce qui est drôle,
c'est qu'il y a eu un moment
où on ne s'est rien dit.
Et tout d'un coup, il me regarde.
Alors forcément, je le regarde.
Et là - je ne saurais
même pas le refaire -
il me dit :
« Alors là, c'est la première fois
qu'un truc pareil m'arrive ! »
(Rires)
On a traversé la rue,
on s'est laissé de l'autre
côté, sur le trottoir.
Et ça a complètement
bouleversé ma journée,
une journée avec des hasards, de la joie.
Ma tristesse s'était complètement envolée.
Donc si je n'avais
qu'une chose à vous dire
de ce que j'ai pu apprendre en cinq ans
de recherche sur le bonheur, c'est :
si vous voulez être heureux, commencez
par rendre quelqu'un heureux,
ça vous rendra immédiatement heureux.
Multipliez, multipliez -
on va commencer avec vous, après,
on fera avec les autres en France -
multipliez, multipliez, et je pense
qu'on va y monter plus vite que prévu
sur ce podium des pays
les plus heureux au monde.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)